and the voices of the police on duty
that day i was slipping in people's
blood
all part of an attempt to persuade
doubters across this country of one
thing
january 6 was the culmination of an
attempted coup
a brazen attempt as one riot to put it
shortly after january 6 to overthrow the
government
the violence was no accident
it represents
senate trump's last stand
most desperate chance to halt the
transfer of power
the committee seven democrats and two
republicans has been sitting in private
for months it's interviewed over a
thousand people subpoenaed nearly a
hundred access nearly 136 000 pages of
records
as you will see in the hearings to come
president trump believed his supporters
at the capitol and i quote
were doing what they should be doing
this is what he told his staff as they
pleaded with him to call off the mob and
among the words we hear for the first
time trump's attorney general i made it
clear i did not agree with
the idea of saying the election was
stolen and putting out this stuff which
i told the president
and this
from the president's daughter how did
that affect your perspective about the
election when attorney general barr made
that statement
it affected my perspective
i respect attorney general barr
so i
accepted what he said was saying but in
america's echo chambers who's listening
here's a hint cnn you will hear that
president trump was yelling nbc you will
see video of them abc all with blanket
coverage
but trump's loyal news channel fox well
they were dismissing it even as it was
live
but we're still talking about january
6th
leesburg virginia is a place with a
civil war history and a more recent
flirtation with donald trump
so what did nancy and her husband make
of it i did watch them from the
beginning and then i actually went back
and i taped them i think that there are
a lot of people who
will not believe it
they are believing what they want to
believe and they select the facts that
they want to support whatever view they
have i think it's important for the
american public to find out the truth
however you never know if you're really
going to get the truth because of how
bipartisan it is so we'll see
as for donald trump well in the absence
of twitter he has his own new social
network and on there he dismissed it all
a one-sided totally partisan political
witch-hunt
his daughter he said had checked out and
bill barr sucks
for the first time since nixon and
watergate a conspiracy is being exposed
to the american public if they choose to
tune in
marc stone sky news in washington